hi it's me Michelle from lab muffin
beauty science I'm a chemistry PhD
graduate who loves skincare science and
today I'm going to be telling you about
how my seller water works my solar water
is a type of cleanser that's super
popular with makeup artists and beauty
addicts the most famous micellar water
is proudly bioderma sensibio h2o
apparently one bottle of this is sold
every five seconds worldwide a quick
chemistry side note it's haste true Oh
as in the letter O not the number zero
this is a pet peeve of mine as a chemist
because he shoe o is the molecular
formula for water what this means is
that there are true hydrogen atoms
bonded to one oxygen atom so we have two
H's and one own h20 would mean that
there are 20 hydrogen's bonded together
which just doesn't happen except maybe
once in a star somewhere anyway back to
my solar water micellar waters are
cleansers that you pour into a cotton
pad then wipe over your skin you don't
need to rinse them after you use them so
it's almost like makeup wipe liquid in a
bottle how do they work we're going to
have to talk about the physical
chemistry of surfactants to understand
what's going on the key ingredients in
my cell water are a surfactant or
multiple surfactants and water oil and
water usually repel each other and all
won't dissolve in water or vice versa
which is why you can't wash an oily dish
with plain water this is because oil is
nonpolar and water is polar
it's like ollas velcro but water is a
magnet they just don't work together
this is a chemical principle that's
commonly known as like dissolves like
which means that oil and water don't
form sticky interactions with each other
but if you add surfactants to the mix
that's a different story
surfactants are nifty little molecules
that have two halves a hydrophilic head
that's attracted to water and repels oil
and a hydrophobic or lipophilic half
that's attracted to oils and grease and
repels water
it's like you've sticky taped a magnet
to Valkyr now everything can stick
together in a big happy heap in
chemistry this happy mixture is called
an emulsion because getting all and
water to hang out together happily is
really handy you'll find surfactants and
lots of products soaps shampoos
dishwashing detergent laundry powders
moisturizers foundations mayonnaise milk
ice cream and of course micellar water
for example with an oily dish the
surfactants and the detergent can sink
into the oil then when you scrub the
dish the surfactants break up the oil
into droplets since the surfactants hang
out at the surface between oil and water
they sort of hide the oil from the water
it's like it's muggles the oil into the
water so you can wash it away it's the
same idea with mayonnaise oil and
vinegar usually don't mix but if you
have lecithin from egg yolk as an
emulsifier or surfactant it can smuggle
in droplets of oil into the vinegar and
they stay together as a thick creamy
delicious group when you use micellar
water you pour the product onto a cotton
pad cotton is made of cellulose which is
polar
so the hydrophilic heads are going to
stick to the cotton like magnets and the
hydrophobic tails are going to stick out
on the surface of the pad like Valkyr
and guess what make up in oils and
grease a non-polar so they're like
velcro as well so when you wipe the pad
over your skin the towels will grab the
makeup and oils and grease so you end up
with clean skin you might be wondering
when I'm going to start talking about my
cells my cells aren't actually that
important to how micellar water works
when you add a surfactant to water
like if you mix dishwashing detergent
with tap water we have the hydrophilic
heads and the hydrophobic tails of the
surfactants and a bunch of water since
the hydrophobic tails don't like water
and the hydrophilic heads do the
surfactant molecules are going to
arrange themselves or self-assemble so
the towels aren't touching the water
they can do this in true ways the towels
can stick out of the water into this air
at the surface sort of like ostriches
burying their heads into the sand or
they can arrange themselves into little
balls with the heads of the surface and
the tails on the inside sort of like
tiny pin cushions these little balls are
called micelles any surfactant in water
will form micelles the main difference
with micellar water is that it's
formulated so that the surfactants
aren't as damaging to your skin as a
standard rinse off cleanser
unfortunately since surfactants us to
heat they tend to stick to things in
your skin such as proteins which changes
the structure of your skin since your
skin's main role is to act as a barrier
to keep water in and unwanted germs and
chemicals out this means that you can
end up with a leaky barrier micellar
waters are made so that the surfactants
won't do this as much as a standard
rinse off cleanser for example they tend
to contain gentler surfactants than a
regular cleanser they're also sometimes
formulated with moisturizing ingredients
like fatty acid esters to keep the skin
barrier intact but for some people who
have sensitive skin even micelle water
might be too much so if you find that
your skin is dry or itchy or tight after
you use micellar water you can try
wiping it off or rinsing it off with a
wet towel or just water so that's how my
cellar water works I hope you found this
video useful if you liked it please
subscribe to my channel check out my
blog follow me on Instagram send me KEK
send me science memes and I'll see you
next time for more beauty science
[Music]